hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde bewertungen sind extrem wichtig
im internet denn man sieht direkt was
andere nutzer von beispielsweise einem
shop einem restaurant oder irgendeiner
anderen einrichtung halten und diese
person die anonym bleiben möchte hat am
freitag dem 06
märz 2020 das essen mit nur einem vom
fuß sternen bewertet die lieferung
allerdings mit vier von fünf sternen
und er begründet das ganze wie folgt ist
denn leider nicht genießbar und ich weiß
auch nicht wieso schon wieder bestellt
habe die sterne für die lieferung weil
der fahrer dieses mal wenigstens nicht
in meinem haus gang gesetzt hat wie beim
letzten mal respekt danke dafür ja auch
sehr stark finde ich diese bewertung von
dem user namens michael der gibt nämlich
einem buch auf amazon nur einen von fünf
sternen mit dem titel ist halt ein buch
und mit der begründung ich hasse bücher
und fünf personen fanden diese
informationen auch noch hilfreich ich
mag bücher auch nicht so gern
bis auf dieses buch denn das ist mein
buch kauft euch jetzt das hallo mein
name ist luca buer auf den nächsten
rezensionen wurde eine spielhalle
bewertet und die userin mit dem namen
sophie punkt gibt dem ganzen nur einen
stern denn ich empfehle nie etwas weiter
korrekte gab alle einmal
so fielen die kommentare schreiben hier
wird ein dönerladen bewertet und eine
person kommentiert wurde beim bestellen
harry potter genannt darf man heutzutage
keine buden mit einem gleichen
dönerladen wurden übrigens auch noch
eine andere bewertung geschrieben und
zwar sehr nette mitarbeiter haben dann
bekommt das gefühl dass sie das gern
machen total verrückt ich weiß fünf
sterne - einstellen weil ich mir einmal
den kopf gestoßen habe
+ einem stern weil hier auf dem boden
plötzlich 50 cent gefunden habe und
kunst aktiv war
warum denkt man wenn man 50 cent findet
dass man super mario ist allerdings
direkt weiter wird der nächste
spitzenteam hier kunden
ich hoffe ich darf lachen ich denke mal
nicht dass diese rezension stimmt
sondern dass sich der anderen spaß
erlaubt hat denn es wurde ein
freizeitpark bewertet und ein user
schreibt war ein super tag aber meine
tochter ist leider auf der großen
achterbahn gestorben trotzdem drei
sterne weil das essen super war
das ist fake hoffe ich hier wird die
jugendvollzugsanstalt moabit also ein
gefängnis in berlin bewertet und nexis
schreibt ansicht toller sg brum es ist
wirklich alles sehr gut gemacht leider
nehmen die mitarbeiter das spiel viel zu
ernst und holen gleich pfefferspray und
schusswaffe hervor wenn man versucht
jedoch teilweise sehr langen runden 1
bis 30 jahre frühzeitig zu beenden zudem
sind die zimmer sind klein und müssen
mit teilweise sehr kriminell aussehenden
fremden geteilt werden
du kriegst von mirial top den humor
preis der woche er ist es das witzigste
auch wenn ich nicht lache aber vom humor
her ist es das witzigste was ich diese
woche gelesen habe wo ich habe nochmals
an das abiturzeugnis durchgelesen das
war ziemlich von ihm an der stelle auch
mal kurz ganz ganz ganz ganz liebe grüße
und ganz gute genesungswünsche an sandra
denn sie hat gestern nacht besoffen
versucht einen rat zu schlagen
dann saß die heute um 12 uhr krankenhaus
und um 17 uhr kam die meldung dass sie
sich zwei bänder gerissen hat in ihrer
schulter und wer das alles mitgeteilt
bekommen weil der notfall kontakt ist
sondern warum gibst du mich als notfall
kontakt ab ich 5 400 kilometer von ihr
entfernt mache mir allerdings weiter mit
den bewertungen und zwar geht es hier um
eine ppp sprachen lernen da das ist
glaube ich irgendwie ein rasierer ist
aber auch egal
auf jeden fall bekommt die person da
unten ein vergleichbares produkt
vorgeschlagen und zwar eine heckenschere
es bräuchte ich eigentlich für
vollbart die nächste bewertung habe ich
auf zalando gefunden und zwar wurden
dort schuhe bewertet die obere
rezensionen dir jetzt eingeblendet heißt
einfach nur schlecht verarbeitet mit
einem stern die untere rezensionen
wiederum dann fünf sterne super schöner
und bequeme schuhe fällt nicht keine
ahnung in schuhe fallen soll
naja es gibt noch eine bewertung in der
mitte und da steht muster haben durila
war damit schlägt perfekt er hat so
bomben bekommen hast du den schulleitern
die hand und dann damit er hier bewertet
jemand das polizeipräsidium stuttgart
und schreibt wurde mit einem kollegen an
einem samstagabend halbtrocken nach
einer grundlosen schlägerei festgenommen
die polizistin machte die shell nicht zu
arg zu und der polizeiwagen war warm
klimatisierte sehr angenehm im wagen
hatten wir viel beinfreiheit im
präsidium wurden gedruckt los
aufgenommen und die u haft zelle war
warm und angenehm wir bekamen eine
flasche wasser um nüchtern zu werden mit
allem drumherum dann ein netter abend
gerne die derart solche leute ganzen
leute diese bewertungen hier schreiben
und wirklich das so witzig meinen auch
der mit der jva moabit mit seiner
komischen jacobs auf ich würde auf jeden
fall gerne mit euch ein bier trinken
gehen oder ein weinchen denn darum geht
es in den nächsten bewertung der
kavernen daumen hoch für dalassen für
die überleitung oder hier wird nämlich
ein gericht bewertet und ein user
schreibt ich kann dieses gerichte nicht
empfehlen habe wegen kümmerlichen zwei
promille den führerschein abgenommen
bekommen in einer weingegend hätte ich
mehr verständnis erwartet bei anderen
gerichten ist man kulanter in der pfalz
gibt es in ähnlichen fällen freispruch
groß wenn es wenn jetzt ein gericht sagt
ach eigentlich wäre das strafmass dass
sie jetzt den führerschein weg bekommen
kann ich war damals schrei
wahrscheinlich schreiben lernen oder
personal war sehr freundlich essen war
toll aber die partner
so waren etwas kleiner als der
europäische durchschnitt eu norm gibt
bei parkplätzen 275 mindestbreite vor
bei diesem mcdonald's allerdings habe
ich nachgemessen und zu meinem bedauern
festgestellt dass die parkplatz breite
lediglich zwei meter sechzig betrug
daher meine ein stern bewertungen liebe
grüße annette da ist die tür da ich habe
zwei türen weil das ist ein großes
zimmer hero ich bin multimilliardär bei
der nächsten bewertung hat sich immerhin
eine plexiglasscheibe online bestellt
und er beschwert sich darüber dass auf
die plexiglasscheibe stempel drauf waren
kann ich auch verstehen eine
plexiglasscheibe designer sondern durch
drücken durch gucken können er schaut
allerdings sind seine bewertung absolut
unbrauchbar mitten auf der
plexiglasscheibe sind mehrere stempel
drauf somit absolut geeignet gegen
direkt prix tour ich glaube als
ungeeignet ist aber auch egal
dann schaut euch einfach mal das bild an
ich will nicht sagen
ich glaube das musst du einfach abziehen
so wie ich letztens ein bier im chaos
der user auto um sein essen mit fünf
sternen oder auch die lieferung mit fünf
sternen und er begründet das ganze wie
folgt ich nehme so salami mit frischer
paprika und dann kommt nur grüne paprika
denke ich mir so nehme man wissen dass
er und dann mühlen wie geil junge der
weiß was abgeht
ich frage mich wirklich gar nichts mehr
wo ich mich auch nichts mehr frage ist
bei dieser bewertung meine lieben
freunde vor villen am passen tut es
perfekt keine frage beim ersten tragen
sind habe jedoch gedacht ich sei
geschlechts krank oder ähnliches der
dash ungewöhnlich rot gewesen ist nach
fünf minuten rätseln habe ich dann den
roten schläppi gesehen wo sich scheinbar
viele kleine rote fesseln gelöst hatten
und am werten hans-georg hängengeblieben
sind okay glücklicherweise habe ich das
set mit verschiedenen farben bestellt
aber ob team für alle ist es natürlich
nicht darum leider nur einen stern weil
es zwar mit den vögeln lustig aussieht
aber mal ganz ehrlich ein preis gewinnt
man damit nicht und 42 personen rannten
diese information auch noch hilfreich
[Musik]
an der stelle oder lieben freunde würde
ich die heutige folge ist das eigentlich
gar keine folge ist ja keine serie
ich würde das video an der stelle auf
jeden fall meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann hast du einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
moniert main kanal und liegt auf die
glocke in den neue videos nicht
verpassen möchte hier noch mal ganz kurz
das am ende zwar keine bewertung aber
lustiger dlc schreibt nämlich jemand
hallo schlüssel hat gesteckt zwei pakete
eingangstür in den bereich schreibt
nicht nur noch drauf herr schlüssel
wieder nicht gestellt war kurz packen
bei euch hat mir was festgemacht
[Musik]